that's a yes Monica I just like to say  yet this is the null vadhaka I just like  to say Joel do you really want to be an  MP would you go into a coalition with  you kids should people be paid to grow  their own what food are we have you got  two kitchens should MPs expenses be cut  should there be a house of lords okay  let's say someone without no it should  be better represented they also laws  with a cross section of the of the  populace rather than its that happens to  be a lot to do it should the BBC take  back Jeremy Clarkson it's our the Stone  Roses better than the happy monday  that's all the pegs what size we focus  yourselves and finally are you twisting  my melon man  you